aimer la nouveau gel est donc notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous c'est
natrice écologiste des Français de
l'étranger on va parler dans quelques
instants la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG puisque c'est vous qui portait ce
combat depuis plusieurs mois mais
d'abord un mot sur la réforme des
retraites puisqu’il évidemment c'est
aussi l'actualité mobilisation
importante il y a deux jours mais le
gouvernement vous l'avez vu reste ferme
sur le cap Elisabeth borne la redit hier
devant vous devant le Sénat mais elle se
dit aussi ouvert à la discussion
parlementaire est-ce que vous pensez
réussir à faire plier le gouvernement
écouter en tout cas tout est réuni pour
que ça fonctionne à la fin on est parti
d'une mobilisation extrêmement forte le
19 janvier au delà de toutes les
expériences des syndicats et des partis
politiques et de toutes celles et ceux
qui combattent cette réforme la
mobilisation s'est amplifiée nettement
le 31 janvier donc tout ce que nous
avait dit toutes les personnes qui nous
racontaient que le mouvement allait
faiblir que ça allait s'épuiser etc
jusqu'ici
le 31 janvier ça non seulement été des
grandes manifestations à Paris à
Marseille à Lyon etc mais ce qui est
très intéressant et qui doit et en tant
que sénatrice on y est très attentifs
c'est la mobilisation dans les petites
villes dans les villages c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui touche toute la
société pas que les grandes villes il y
avait un chiffre qui m'a interpellé hier
sur la mobilisation c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres parce qu'il y a plein
d'exemples mais la ville d'Annonay par
exemple en Ardèche il y a 16000
habitants selon la police 3000 de 19
janvier 7000 selon la police le 30 donc
un habitant sur deux Annonay et descendu
dans la rue pour lutter contre la
réforme des retraites c'est la ville
dont Olivier du sof était mère je crois
que ça dit quelque chose sur l'ampleur à
travers la société entière de la
mobilisation donc si le gouvernement
persiste je vois pas comment on va pas
vers un conflit qui s'amplifie et qui à
la fin va avoir raison de l'entêtement
du gouvernement
on va parler de l'actualité du Sénat
évidemment actualités hier c'est un vote
qui n'était pas forcément attendu vous
allez nous le dire le Sénat donc voter
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution on va voir les temps forts
de cette séance et on va longuement en
parler avec vous Audrey nous rejoindre
[Musique]
bonjour et Audrey le Sénat a donc
accepté hier d'inscrire sur le principe
et avec des ajustements on va en parler
l'IVG dans la Constitution on peut dire
que c'est un coup de théâtre oui je
dirais même qu'on peut parler d'un vote
historique inattendu en tout cas parce
que la majorité sénatoriale de droite
était opposée à ce texte alors le texte
a donc été adopté à une très courte
majorité 166 voix pour 152 voix contre
il y a eu beaucoup d'abstention il y a
eu aussi 16 sénateurs et sénatrices LR
qui ont voté pour ils n'étaient que deux
sur un texte similaire votre texte mais
le niveau gel à l'automne dernier alors
on va rentrer dans les détails ensuite
parce que de la rédaction que vous
satisfait pas mais déjà une première
réaction hier vous avez dit être très
ému oui j'étais très très émue à la
sortie du vote vous le disiez c'était
c'était inattendu mais c'était pas
impossible on y croyait c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a fait et c'est ses émotions
qu'on a quand on est dans un moment
qu'on sait historique il y a plus de
débats en France aujourd'hui sur est-ce
qu'il faut inscrire le droit dans la
Constitution ce débat est derrière nous
il y a une discussion à venir sur
comment l'écrit à quel endroit on le met
dans la Constitution c'est des
discussions qui sont tout à fait
légitimes qu'on va avoir dans les mois
qui viennent mais on a remporté une
bataille qui est immense et qui répond
et je voulais revenir sur ces mois qui
est porté au départ c'est les mouvements
féministes qui ont porté cette réforme
qui ont porté ce combat c'est grâce au
mouvement féministe dans la rue et au
féminisme dans les institutions qu'on y
est arrivé donc c'est pas ma victoire
c'est la victoire des féministes en
général en France mais aussi à travers
le monde et je reçois beaucoup de
messages de féministe partout en Pologne
en Allemagne etc qui nous disent merci
quoi parce que ça va nous donner un une
impulsion pour nos combats dans des pays
où c'est beaucoup plus dur immense ça
vous a étonné ce vote on va revenir
évidemment sur le fond mais c'est vrai
qu'on a entendu beaucoup de critiques
sur un sénat supposé conservateur est-ce
que du coup vous avez été surprise de ce
qui s'est passé hier c'était
[Musique]
celui du droit des femmes pour une fois
le Sénat arrive à être au fond en
dialogue en cohérence avec ce que
demande la société et ça c'est une
victoire au-delà d'être une victoire
féministe c'est une victoire
démocratique alors ça a pas été facile
même hier Audrey la séance a été tendue
rapidement des batailles finissent
facile c'est souvent le cas sur les
sujets sociétaux comme celui-ci hier
encore plus parce que le texte était
inscrit dans une niche parlementaire la
niche des socialiste il y a donc un
timing très précis à 20h45 tout est fini
qu'on est voté ou non alors quand
l'heure a commencé à avancer évidemment
les esprits ont commencé à s'échauffer
encore plus quand plusieurs sénateurs
centristes ou les républicains ont
demandé à prendre la parole alors qu'il
s'était déjà exprimé autant vous dire
que ça n'a pas plu à la sénatrice PS
Laurence Rossignol qui a dénoncé une
tentative d'ostruction on va l'écouter
et dans la foulée on écoute la réponse
de Loïc Hervé sénateur sans triste
directement visé
je vois les inscrits
s'afficher de plus en plus nombreux au
fur et à mesure du débat je vois même
des collègues qui ont ce qu'ils ont
exprimés dans la discussion générale
s'inscrire de nouveau sur l'article donc
je ne voudrais pas que le Sénat ayant
déjà il y a quelques temps au mois
d'octobre était remarqué pour son vote
hostile à la Constitution soit
aujourd'hui remarquer pour une manœuvre
de procédures qui consisterait à faire
durer le débat et à ce que nous ne
puissions pas voter aujourd'hui on a le
droit monsieur le Président d'avoir le
temps nécessaire pour débattre de ces de
ces différentes rédactions qui touchent
au texte fondamental de la République
française et moi ce projet d'intention
là je ne l'entends pas et c'est pas fini
Oriane climax au moment de
l'intervention du sénateur reconquête
Stéphane Ravier dans la tribune des
visiteurs des militantes se mettent à
hurler pour défendre l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est
extrêmement on ne rentre pas au Sénat
comme ça une photo du contre-champ parce
qu'on ne le voit pas à la réalisation
que je vais vous montrer après autant
vous dire qu'on n'interrompt pas non
plus une séance au Sénat comme cela je
vais vous laisser revivre ce moment
pourquoi cette proposition pourquoi
cette obsession de la gauche la
principale raison la frustration la
frustration politique la loi de
dépénalisation de 1900 la loi de 1975
tout de suite donnez-moi la parole la
séance est suspendue
huissier évacuer la tribune évacuer la
tribu si jeunes donc on le voit
suspension de séance vous étiez hier
dans l'hémicycle c'est possible de nous
dire un petit mot sur l'ambiance et puis
qui a invité finalement ces militantes
alors je ne sais pas qui a invité ces
militantes et c'est vrai que ça arrive
pas souvent au Sénat donc en général je
pense que ça a surpris ça nous a surpris
les huissiers aussi voilà après le
moment pour cette action était s'il en
fallait un plutôt bien choisi puisque
l'intervention du sénateur à vie était
scandaleuse tout est interventions
étaient scandaleuses donc voilà c'est
vrai que c'est un moment inhabituel pour
comment vous avez senti l'ambiance
pendant cette séance alors on sentait
que la droite était
fébrile puisque et c'est là c'est ce que
vous avez montré de l'intervention de
Laurence Rossignol il faisait il
s'inscrivait pour pour parler pour
répéter des arguments qu'ils avaient
déjà dit la main de fois et on sentait
bien qu'ils étaient pas sûr
de leur de leur troupe et c'est ce qui
s'est passé à la fin et on sentait bien
que voilà il y avait une recherche à
éviter le vote en finalement prenant la
parole jusqu'à ce que le délai soit
passé pour pouvoir passer au vote Audrey
on parle du fond du texte oui tant qu'à
faire c'est intéressant aussi un peu de
contexte d'abord en octobre une
proposition similaire la vôtre mais la
niveau gel j'en ai parlé et retoquée par
le Sénat plusieurs motifs invoqués par
la commission des lois notamment et par
la majorité de droite le texte n'est pas
bien écrit le droit à l'IVG n'est pas
menacé en France et on ne modifie pas la
Constitution aussi facilement
l'assemblée prend acte et fait une
nouvelle proposition trans partisane en
prenant en compte certaines remarques du
Sénat rien n'y fait c'est insuffisant
pour Agnès canailler la rapporterait
l'air de la commission des lois mais et
c'est assez surprenant Philippe Bas
sénateur LR il faut le rappeler ancien
collaborateur de Simone Veil aussi fait
une autre proposition il propose à
écrire totalement le texte pour la
petite histoire l'automne dernier sa
collègue sénatrice socialiste
Marie-Pierre delagonerie il avait accusé
d'être en fait opposé à l'IVG et de se
cacher derrière la rédaction une
mauvaise rédaction de la loi il semble
qu'il était piqué il annonce donc cette
nouvelle version ou le droit des femmes
devient une liberté on l'écoute on
écoute ensuite les réactions à cette
proposition
chers collègues je vous propose
d'effacer totalement la proposition qui
nous vient de l'Assemblée nationale pour
écrire que la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse c'est une formule qu'on
retrouve fréquemment dans l'énoncé des
libertés constitutionnelles elle permet
de préserver l'équilibre de la loi
veille je le dis au président bail je le
dis à vous tous l'IVG n'est pas
seulement une liberté pour nous c'est un
droit
mais cette rédaction proposée à la vertu
de s'engager sur le chemin de la
constitutionnalisation notre groupe la
soutiendra comme étant positive même si
elle est imparfaite est-il raisonnable
de vouloir constitutionnaliser à tout va
Dominique delajat a très bien dit demain
si on a par exemple le droit au suicide
assisté il y a la paix à n'importe
pourquoi donc ces droits serait-il de
porter inférieur la Constitution
française de la 5ème république elle
n'est pas faite pour adresser des
messages symboliques au monde entier
alors là je pense qu'il faut s'arrêter
cinq minutes Philippe Bas et donc
soutenu par la gauche prête au compromis
et désavoué par son propre président de
groupe et par la commission c'est
finalement son texte qui est adopté à 14
voix près on l'a dit au début de cette
chronique un texte qui a divisé les LR
mais le niveau
les LR et parce que
manifestement il y a pas uniquement dans
la majorité sénatoriale républicaine des
personnes attachées à systématiquement
s'opposer à toutes les avancées sociales
voulues par la société française voilà
il y en a 16 qui voulaient quand même
essayer de répondre à cette attente donc
je m'en félicite la formulation vous
l'avez dit c'est pas la mienne elle est
pas parfaite elle est pas aussi
protectrice que ce qu'on voudrait parce
qu'au fond je veux pas faire un cours de
droit constitutionnel mais pour bien
comprendre la formulation de Philippa
elle entérine
excusez-moi ce qu'on sait depuis de
nombreuses années qui est que il est de
du domaine de la loi de pouvoir
légiférer sur l'avortement et elle
laisse énormément de liberté au
législateur pour déterminer les
conditions et puis elle parle de liberté
et non pas de droit et il y a une
différence importante juridique c'est
qu'un droit ça implique que l'État vous
doit quelque chose pour que vous
puissiez accéder à ce droit alors qu'une
liberté elle est inhérente à votre
personne et au fond on vous doit juste
de ne pas vous empêcher de l'exercer
donc c'est très différent néanmoins
c'est un chemin c'est un chemin et dans
la majorité qu'on a c'était hier soir le
seul chemin possible pour faire avancer
ce combat c'est pour ça qu'on l'a qu'on
l'a soutenu vous avez hésité quand même
on a discuté longuement de la meilleure
stratégie et je crois que à bien des
égards et je les dis hier dans
l'hémicycle aussi c'est une situation
qui était au fond un peu similaire à ce
qui s'est passé en 1974 quand on a dû
voter la loi veille la loi V n'était pas
la loi que vous voulez la gauche c'était
pas la loi que vous voulez les
féministes elle n'allait pas assez loin
il y avait que 10 semaines c'était pas
remboursé il y avait la clause de
détresse et il y avait pas le délit
d'entre enfin bref c'était pas la loi
qu'on voulait d'ailleurs on l'a beaucoup
amélioré depuis néanmoins un moment
donné ça a été le compromis le seul
possible je dis pas que celui-là est le
seul possibilité il faut l'améliorer
mais à un moment donné c'était ce qu'il
fallait faire en tant que féministe pour
que le combat puisse un jour aboutir et
c'est ça qu'on a qu'on a fait hier c'est
prendre nos responsabilités pour dire
voilà c'est ça qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui on le prend pour que demain
on puisse aboutir on va justement parler
de la suite du texte qu'est-ce qui va se
passer à l'Assemblée parce que les
versions du Sénat et de l'assemblée sont
maintenant différentes on dit que c'est
non conforme alors la navette continue
mais il y a un point sur lequel je
voulais insister c'est qu'il y a une
différence quand c'est le Parlement qui
propose un texte ou qu'on sait le
gouvernement si c'est une initiative de
l'Assemblée ou du Sénat il faut ensuite
entériner cela par un référendum demandé
leur avis aux Français si c'est le
gouvernement pas besoin et en fait
beaucoup de parlementaires je pense que
vous en faites partie mais la niveau gel
demande à ce que le gouvernement
s'empare et propose un texte pour éviter
un référendum qui pourrait diviser la
société ou ne pas parler des bonnes
questions ça a donné lieu hier à une
passe d'armes avec Philippe Bas encore
lui écoutez-le
monsieur le garde des sceaux vous avez
dit tout à l'heure rappelant une formule
célèbre qu'il ne fallait toucher à la
constitution que d'une main tremblante
les vôtres sont restés dans vos poches
et il me semble et il me semble qu'on
aurait tout de même intérêt puisque vous
critiquez un certain nombre de rédaction
avoir celle que le gouvernement pourrait
nous soumettre après avis du Conseil
d'État
est-ce que vous pensez que l'adoption de
ce type social peut mettre la pression
sur le gouvernement pour qu'il propose
un texte incontestablement il y a
maintenant plus de débats sur le fait
que le Parlement en France c'est deux
chambres veut inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution il y a un débat sur
comment le faire et comment faire pour
que ce soit vraiment protecteur c'est à
dire pour que ça permette que si le
législateur veut attaquer le droit à
l'avortement le Conseil constitutionnel
puisse l'en empêcher c'est pour ça qu'on
veut le faire c'est pas pour faire joli
ni pour envoyer un message symbolique au
monde
maintenant on sait très bien que pour
plusieurs raisons le chemin du projet de
loi est le meilleur chemin tout d'abord
parce que vous l'avez dit ça permet
d'éviter le référendum personne ne veut
un référendum sur la question à quoi ça
sert d'aller demander aux Français qui
disent à 86% qui veulent cette avancée
est-ce qu'ils le veulent vraiment par
référendum ensuite un référendum on
répond rarement à la question qu'on vous
a posée je crois qu'on n'est pas dans un
moment où les Français sont très tendre
avec ce que fait le gouvernement donc je
suis pas convaincu que ce soit le
meilleur moment pour leur poser cette
question et puis ça donne une tribune
pendant des mois à toutes les personnes
qui au-delà de ce débat sur la
constitutionnalisation s'oppose au droit
à l'avortement en soi donc c'est pas une
bonne idée donc il faut un projet de loi
pour pour éviter ça et puis aussi pour
qu'on puisse débattre dans des
conditions non dégradées pas dans des
niches parlementaires où on a deux
heures et une possibilité très limitée
de travailler sur le contenu vraiment
profondément il faut que le gouvernement
entendent voilà vous avez une volonté
parlementaire il y a une majorité vous
avez la majorité pour le faire
maintenant faites travailler vos
administrations proposez-nous un projet
de loi qui puisse mettre d'accord les
deux chambres qui évite le référendum
qu'on adopte au Congrès et qu'on passe à
autre chose mais vous en doutez parce
que Emmanuel Macron il a jamais montré
un grand enthousiasme sur l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est vrai
et je pense que dans le gouvernement il
y a effectivement des des débats
néanmoins un peu de cohérence Emmanuel
Macron a plaidé l'année dernière pour
que le droit à l'IVG soit inscrit dans
la Charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'Union européenne moi je veux bien
c'est très bien mais pour inscrire le
droit libéger dans l'achat des droits
fondamentaux il faut l'unanimité des
états peut-être commencer par son propre
état d'accord qu'on dirait soi-même ce
serait quand même acte de cohérence je
pense minimum merci Audrey merci résumé
très complet de cette séance évidemment
et on voulait en parler longuement avec
vous mais la niveaujeel puisque vous
avez quand même porté ce combat ici au
Sénat depuis longtemps on va parler d'un
autre texte on va parler du projet de lo
immigration d'abord on va aller à
Perpignan pour parler de ce sujet on
retrouve pierre Mathis bonjour Pierre
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef de l'indépendant
pierre vous allez revenir sur un épisode
récent autour de la frontière entre la
France et l'Espagne
oui bonjour Oriane moi j'ai décidé de
revenir ce matin sur ce qui est arrivé
il y a une petite dizaine de jours ici à
au col de Banyuls à la frontière
franco-espagnole qui est un lieu un lieu
de passage qui est fermé par la
préfecture des pérides de orientale donc
par l'État depuis déjà plusieurs mois
avec des gros on voit sur la photo il y
a des gros rochers qui empêchent les
véhicules de passer et il y a une
dizaine de jours de ça côté côté catalan
côté de l'État espagnol du côté des
Catalans du Sud il y a il y a les
habitants d'un village de juste de
l'autre côté qui faisait une fête de
l'olive qui est en général qui attire
toujours beaucoup de monde des deux
côtés de la frontière de nuit ils ont
amené des bulldozers et ils ont ils ont
enlevé c'était ils ont enlevé ses
rochers que la préfecture de des PO d'un
rubis en place que que après la fête
après la fête de l'olive donc ce qui est
intéressant dans cette dans cette
affaire c'est que l'État français
explique que
la circulation ne sera ouverte
que lorsque les Espagnols feront de leur
côté des des patrouilles communes
puisque bien évidemment se colle il est
fermé parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
passages de parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
passages de de de migrer en dessin enfin
de clandestins qui viennent évidemment
de du Maghreb qui remonte à travers
l'Espagne et qui et qui passe là
passailleurs aussi mais enfin c'est cet
endroit qui est c'est cet endroit qui
est qui est fermé et donc on voit bien
que très concrètement dans la vie
quotidienne de plusieurs villages et
dans la vie aussi quotidienne de de de
de région qui qui sont de ce côté d'une
frontière cette affaire des migrations
elle est extrêmement concrète sur la sur
la côte vermeil il y a beaucoup
d'endroits où on retrouve des traces de
passage des des émigrés clandestins et
donc voilà on a on est on est confronté
à cette à cette à cette difficulté là
ici ici dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
très concrètement on voit bien que les
migrations les migrations arrivent les
migrants arrivent et tentent de passer
des temps en état donc la question que
ça pose évidemment et on va demander une
question à la sénatrice c'est savoir si
le contrôle au frontières doit être une
certaine façon rétablie ou en tout cas
revues pour justement essayer de essayer
de de contrôler cette immigration
clandestine
moi je crois pas que la question qui se
pose là ce soir enfin que la bonne
réponse à la question en général de
l'immigration en Europe ce soit celle de
rétablir des frontières entre les États
européens à l'intérieur de l'espace
Schengen avec des rochers je veux dire
ça n'a jamais un empêcher personne de
traverser une frontière d'accord ça ne
fonctionne pas on voit bien d'ailleurs
que cette politique c'est symbolique de
mettre des rochers sur la route les gens
passent à côté des rochers mais elle
embête en plus les habitants des deux
côtés de la frontière et puis elle ne
résout absolument rien à la question
fondamentale comment on gère les flux
migratoires aujourd'hui au niveau
européen dans un contexte où ils vont du
fait de diverses crises augmenter la
vraie réponse c'est pas quatre rocher
sur une route c'est une révision globale
de notre cadre d'Asie des migration au
niveau européen puisque
il est inopérant pour beaucoup de
raisons il met la responsabilité unique
première sur les pays d'accueil donc
c'est très déséquilibré il permet pas de
de pouvoir ventiler correctement les les
migrants éventuellement les réfugiés au
sein de l'Union européenne donc la vraie
réponse elle doit être européenne en
aucun cas une fermeture de frontières à
l'intérieur de l'espace Schengen n'a
jamais résolu quoi que ce soit un mot
pierre
effectivement le projet européen est-il
compatible avec ce genre de ce genre de
mesure on voit bien que les habitants
des spoil qui sont cotés catalogue du
Sud on vit de communiquer avec avec les
habitants de l'autre côté de la
frontière et on peut se demander si
effectivement c'est un sens aujourd'hui
dans l'Europe telle qu'elle est
construite dans les interactions
européennes aujourd'hui de de de vouloir
contrôler les frontières nationales de
bloquer des routes et d'empêcher la lips
circulation y compris des Européens
parce que on n'est pas capable d'avoir
politique convenable humaine et censé
d'Asie et migration niveau européen donc
la réponse je suis d'accord avec vous
enfin de ce que je comprends de ce que
vous dites la réponse elle doit être
européenne par la révision de notre
cadre de notre cas de législatif
européen un mot juste sur le projet de
votre une pierre mais un mot sur le
projet de la migration puisqu'il a été
présenté hier en conseil des ministres
et à la fois démesure pour faciliter les
expulsions c'est la partie fermeté comme
dit le gouvernement il y a une deuxième
partie humanité ce que dit le
gouvernement est notamment ce titre de
séjour pour les travailleurs étrangers
dans les métiers en tension est-ce que
c'est un projet que vous pourriez
discuter amender ou pour vous c'est non
non moi je
veux bien toujours discuter de toute
façon mais la partie fermeté comme il
l'appelle et elle est parfaitement
absurde à la fois je pense que il y a
beaucoup de dispositions qui ne sont pas
constitutionnels qui ne sont pas non
plus conformes à nos engagements
internationaux elle elle part d'une
idéologie j'entends déjà maintenant qui
consiste à dire le top dans la vie c'est
quand même d'expulser le maximum de
monde possible alors que ça répond pas à
des arguments
réalistes c'est à dire beaucoup de monde
qui ne sont pas expulsés c'est parce
qu'ils sont pas expulsables et puis et
puis c'est une fin ça participe d'une
logique qui consiste à dire que
l'immigration est nécessairement un
problème et qui ne résout rien sur le
terrain les aspects que vous appelez
enfin qu'il appelle humanité moi je veux
bien discuter de la manière dont on
régularise des gens qui travaillent
aujourd'hui qui participent à notre
économie sans aucun droit c'est
malheureusement une logique utilitariste
le prendre sur les métiers en tension
etc mais moi
s'il y a des dispositifs qui peuvent qui
peuvent permettre d'améliorer la vie des
gens en vrai sur le terrain je suis
ouverte à en discuter pierre amour
rapidement de votre une des
propriétaires se rebiffent
oui alors sujet intéressant c'est un
quartier de la vieille ville de
Perpignan qui est à quartier difficile
un quartier où on trouve beaucoup de
populations gitane et maghrébines et
dans le cadre de sa rénovation on a une
enquête de l'indépendance et elle ce
matin que des maisons étaient détruites
alors que les propriétaires ont reçu la
notice la notification des huissiers
quelques heures avant et alors surtout
que les propriétaires se battaient
depuis des années pour justement que la
mairie qui était propriétaire de
l'immeuble à côté
solidifie cet immeuble parce que avait
fait de leur côté des travaux donc on se
rend compte que l'intérêt de cette de
cette enquête et de montrer que la
rénovation démolition c'est pas la même
merci beaucoup pierre Mathis d'avoir été
avec nous on regarde la Une de
l'indépendant un dernier mot sur une
question qui concerne votre partie c'est
Julien Bayou qui avait été accusé de
violents psychologiques par une
ex-compagnière on a appris que la
cellule interne d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts avec Claude dossier faute d'avoir
pu mener à bien son enquête qu'est-ce
que ce que vous en pensez c'est
évidemment une une décision qui au fond
à la fois est logique puisque la
personne qui avait effectué le
signalement n'a pas souhaité dans les
conditions qu'on pouvait lui offrir
venir témoigner donc à partir de là il
est assez logique qu'on ne puisse pas
conclure néanmoins c'est évidemment pas
satisfaisant je crois pas pour cette
personne pas pour Julien Baillou et pas
pour nous comme par-ci puisqu'il
évidemment je crois que tout le monde
aurait préféré que ça se termine par une
décision substantielle plus claire
maintenant je pense que ça doit nous
faire réfléchir plus largement est-ce
que on peut et comment améliorer notre
notre mécanisme on a été le premier
parti à mettre en place cette cellule
dans un contexte de nos propres
défaillances suite à la faire beau pain
aussi de défaillance de la justice
ce système il est pas parfait on est en
train de l'auditionner et je suis
ouverte comme tous les écologistes à
réfléchir à la meilleure manière
possible pour que ça se passe mieux je
crois qu'on a encore un peu de travail à
faire merci Mélanie merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin dans
20 minutes dans le club on parlera de la
mobilisation contre la réforme de
retraite chez les saisonniers dans les
stations de ski on verra l'impact
notamment alors que les vacances d'hiver
commence mais d'abord on va parler de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est Christian Cambon
qui nous rejoint